Browsing eclectic street markets and stalls...
...is an enduring memory of any visit to the world's favorite city.
It is said you can buy almost anything in Paris without ever entering a store.
From the flower growers and booksellers of Saint-Germain to the artists of Boulevard Edgar Quinet,...
...the market culture thrives.
And at the center of it all is food.
The French passion for gastronomy has seen entire streets declared food markets permanently,...
...open only to pedestrian traffic.
One of the most popular amongst Parisians is Rue Cler and Davoli is their favorite shop.
Named after the family who runs it, dropping in to this frantically busy delicatessen...
...is a daily ritual for the locals of the 7th arrondissement.
We're serving the embassy, actors and everybody.
Stephane Davoli is continuing a family tradition that began in Italy.
My god, it's a long, long story.
My grandfather migrated to France and he opened his first shop in the 16th district.
So I'm the fourth generation of the Italian delis in Paris.
The family spends 11 hours a day in the shop...
...preparing, cooking, cleaning and serving customers.
Their reputation guarantees there are always hungry locals to feed.